donc tu es un chien moi je suis Batman
les animaux c'est pas trop mon truc
ouais les hommes c'est pas trop mon truc
probablement suite au traumatisme de mon
enfance quand j'étais petit ma famille
m'a été enlevée quand j'étais chaud on
m'a enlevé à ma famille alors je me suis
endurci mes émotions sont toujours ce
contrôle nul ne peut percer mes défenses
infranchissables
[Musique]
allez tant pis
ça c'est vraiment pas hygiénique
tous les jours supplément entraîne
ensemble
tu vénères carrément le seul sur lequel
il marche techniquement il vole Batman
ne travaille avec personne sauf avec
Robin et Alfred et le commissaire Gordon
et mon équipe informatique et le gars
joué par Morgan Freeman et qu'est-ce que
c'est ça
[Musique]
il faudrait mieux que ce soit un produit
dérivé officiel sinon je pars en vrai